so many of you guys have asked if I'm
going to make a video about the Samsung
Galaxy fold but I don't have one to make
a video about I guess I must be too much
of an apple fangirl which I get it but
let's not forget I do always have a
second device that is an Android phone
and right now my second device is in
Samsung Galaxy S 10 I did just finish up
a video coming out this week with the
s10 plus and the s10 you because I'd
seen so many great reviews about the s10
EE that I really wanted to get one and
try it out for myself so look for that
later this week but the Samsung Galaxy
fold has had so much drama this past
month that is kind of shocking so
unfortunately I did try to order one but
of course they pushed the release date
further and further away because they
had a small little problem I'm sure most
of you guys are already well aware that
they had a lot of screen issues with the
fold from debris kind of sneaking in
between the screen and then some people
have tried to peel away the top screen
in the middle although I feel like
people aren't really that shocked that
this phone was faulty and it's weird
because I feel like if Samsung would
have done any kind of testing on this
phone at all they would have realized
that there was a small issue I just
don't really get like you are a huge
company how could something like this go
so terribly wrong like if this was Apple
and this happened it would be such a
huge deal not this isn't a big deal but
I feel like everyone's just kind of
giving Samsung a pass like it's okay you
tried we realized that your phones were
exploding and blowing up in people's
hands that's all right but if it was
Apple it would be a whole nother freakin
story like come on now even if you're an
Android fan you can't say that that's
not the case because it definitely is
one thing that I do applaud Samsung for
is actually going through with this
device and releasing it but I feel like
if they would have just maybe push the
release date a little bit further fix
the problems that they initially had
because there's no way that they knew
that this was something that wasn't
gonna become a widespread issue even if
you tell someone to not peel up a screen
but if something is that simple that can
completely render this phone useless
then I feel like you may have wanted to
implement something before releasing it
one thing that I do even think that's
great about Apple is they didn't release
air power I'm upset about it I'm sad I'm
still bitter I just don't know how to
feel I had a lot of emotions the day
that they announced that they were
canceling it but they
did cancel it all of the reviews that I
have seen like I am really excited to
try this phone out because it is
something that is different and I feels
like right now most phones are pretty
much the same so for Samsung to take
this completely new approach is really
exciting and it definitely is pushing
the technology further because they
tried they failed and hopefully the next
version will be something that we can
actually use again this phone I don't
think was ever meant to be a widespread
phone it is set at such a high price
point that only people who are crazy
like most of us tech people and
reviewers and people who do love to have
the latest and greatest and most
expensive phone those are the people
that are gonna buy that that phone is
not something that is meant to be used
by everyone so setting that price high
was already cutting out most of the
general public that still doesn't mean
that you should have released something
that you know was not gonna work so
either way I just wanted to make like a
super short video just talking about it
with a few of my thoughts because it is
something that I'm extremely excited to
check out yes I'm an Apple fan but I
appreciate technology I appreciate
anyone who is going to try to push
technology further because I feel like
this is going to be the future this is
going to be the next thing folding
phones folding devices because trying to
take what we have now and make it
smaller and compact is what everyone
wants we want bigger screens but we want
a smaller profile how do you make that
happen you freaking folding so Samsung
I'm super excited to try this phone out
and I'm hoping that the changes the
Samsung does make when they actually do
release this phone will make this phone
function properly it's so hard to watch
people's reviews of this phone because
without actually having it or touching
it and seeing it in person it's hard to
say what the display looks like because
one of the things that I did notice in a
lot of these reviews if you could see
that crease I know Mark has mentioned
this that you see it in pictures in a
video but when you're actually holding
it in front of you it's not as
noticeable I would love to hear from you
guys do you think that Samsung released
this a little bit too early what do you
think would have happened if this was
Apple that did this I will see you guys
in the next video and be sure to look
for my samsung s 10 plus + s tiny video
that'll be out very shortly and the
meantime I have nothing else to say so
I'll see you guys later
[Music]